[Music]
this is the real thing we want to cheers
to you guys cheers to season to
congratulate let's talk about it there
nice to have planned employment for next
year it's like I've never had employment
this far out in my whole life but you
know I love you I love the most is the
back now Luke was just saying it before
he started now we know how it works yes
so the next time around now it gets even
better because we understand how the
whole thing works great we're kind of
going in there who are these kids
honestly I look back as the first one
and I'm like I can't believe we have to
do like months with this I know he's
like my brother
see farts and burps and fun let me ask
you guys then what did it take to get
everybody to sign on did everybody get
their money yeah we doubled it all of us
double you know the truth of the matter
is as we know that we're having an
effect on people and they're having an
effect on us that my friend is priceless
what change is what things do you want
to try for season two bigger hair I'm
gonna get some you know I'm gonna do
some Botox next year no I gotta get with
Lionel's guy he's going to he's going to
have more hair I'm going to pray
[Music]